hey guys and welcome back to the game
spot stage here at e3 2016 I'm Mary and
I'm going to be your host for the next
two full hours and I'm delighted to be
joined by my very best friend and
gamespot review editor Peter Brown what
an introduction I know there is nothing
better for you and the community manager
for bungee this is deej nice to be have
you guys here thank you I should be here
and obviously we're going to start this
off by talking about what everybody
wants talked about which is rise of iron
the latest upcoming the expansion for
destiny all of that is absolutely right
yeah rise of iron is a large expansion
to the Destiny universe it's coming up
this fall februari 20th we're telling
new stories in new places where you'll
be fighting new enemies acquiring new
weapons and armor making your character
powerful in new ways this is something
that we just revealed just prior to III
got to have a conversation with our
community on twitch interviewed to some
of the developers who are also here with
me at e3 it's part of our bungee away
team and we're really excited to be
welcoming the Guardians back to destiny
to continue their adventures and evolve
their characters and some brand new and
exciting ways it sounds like you guys
have been constantly working with the
players to see and get feedback back and
forth and one of the main things that
yeah I'm sure you guys were very eagerly
anticipating was the announcement of the
gala horn and bringing that back can you
tell us a little bit more about it is
going to be as powerful as it once was
well the gala horn will be actually even
more powerful because it's going to its
power levels are going to need to rise
so that it can help the Guardians
confront this new threat they have an
all new enemy to fight the gala horn
will be restored to its old prowess it
was one of the most iconic weapons in
the first year of destiny that's uh and
we're really looking forward to putting
it back into the hands of the players
every Guardian is going to forge their
own galloran as part of a quest so
whereas they may be used to waiting for
it to drop as a random reward in an
activity now it is something that's a
guaranteed virtue as the completion for
a quest now tell me a little bit about
the plaguelands zone
what's it comparable to and there are
any new mechanics if the plaguelands
have a bunch of new surprises for
players it's a landscape that is forever
transformed by the outbreak of a
technological plague the Fallen have
discovered that force of technology
they're using it to twist their minds
and their bodies in a bid to become
machine gods so the players of Destiny
are going to infiltrate the plaguelands
a zone that has for a long time been
forbidden from exploration so in rise of
iron were welcoming them to go into that
space they're going to be all sorts of
new ways to patrol the plaguelands
there's going to be new public events
things that bring guardians together who
have never met before to enjoy a moment
of action new story missions we have
strikes we have raids rise of iron
satisfies every player of destiny with
the infusion of new action and adventure
across the entire spectrum of the player
experience now to our new fallen foes
have any new moves that we should be
aware of that current ones don't yeah
they've got some they got some surprises
up their sleeve they fight in some
interesting new ways they die and some
interesting new ways wait a studio wide
play test on Friday just before we came
down to e3 which was great for me to
really be able to put eyes on what we
were going to be talking about you know
and lay hands on a controller and
experience it myself and it's always
great when you're facing a new foe
because when something new catches your
eye and something takes you by surprise
i mean that's that's part of the Destiny
player experience it's they're supposed
to be moments that surprise you it's
supposed to be relatable but also packed
with new and interesting things to you
know entertain and delight because I've
been working on expansions for a while
now and I'm curious do you feel that
you've sort of hit a stride where you
understand what the playerbase wants and
how to both deliver upon that and
surprise them I think definitely we walk
and talk differently as developers than
we did the first year of destiny destiny
was a very new thing for Bungie we were
certainly used to making first-person
shooters and story-driven experiences
but we've never had a game that was this
ambitious you know with the scope and
the scale and the all you know the
persistent connectivity the persistent
character progression you know we were
delving into a lot of new things for us
now that we understand who our audiences
now that we know who our audiences and
we know where we could listen to them
and get engage in conversation with them
certainly uh you know there is a
collaboration you know we can take a lot
of inspiration from them you know we
inspire them to do awesome things they
inspire us to do awesome things in terms
of hitting a stride I mean this is the
fourth expansion in you know just under
two years so we've delivered pretty
frequent content updates of course any
player of a game that truly loves that
game wants more content all the time you
know we'd love to be able to satisfy
that urge but at the same time we want
to create things that we think are
worthy of the passion and enthusiasm
that they've invested into the game that
we've invested into creating that world
for them to explore so it's a healthy
balance we have people who create
experiences like rise of iron to tell
new stories and expand the boundaries of
the world of destiny we also have a live
team and they're constantly giving
players fresh reasons to come back to
the game limited time events even if
it's just things that we did like in
April where was like new gear sets new
playable activities bringing new
features online we've got this chroma
system now wear your armor can glow in
different colors it's not just about
kicking ass and making stuff blow up
it's about a game that is enabling your
own creative expression yeah is the
character that you create is an
expression of who you feel at you would
be as a hero in this world I look at the
equipment sets and I look at my friends
who play this game a lot and one of the
things that they're very attracted to
are the armor you know and the weapons
that they get and I look at those things
and the design is so distinct compared
to a lot of other games destiny is very
fashionable in that sense I feel like I
want to know more about how you go about
designing these things and you know
maybe when something has taken the
design a little bit too far like how do
you actually define like this fits the
destiny visual style or this is
redefining the Desilijic I think
creating a character and and making that
character powerful and making that
character unique is an enormous
component of you know the player fantasy
yeah you know so the art team takes a
look at the archetypes that we want to
create you know at a glance you can take
a look at different players of destiny
and you can say you know this warlock
that is adorned in iron banner gear
looks like a heraldic night they're a
champion of the crucible this hard core
raider looks like it's wearing the teeth
of an
ormus final boss this person is a hard
core raider this person is decked out in
the color scheme of a faction so either
you really love to wear black or you're
interested in the dead orbit lure you
know sort of like this nihilistic
spacefaring desperation so what we want
to do is we want to give players an
opportunity to create a character that
they feel reflects their imagination
right and then also provide evidence and
signposts to the other players of the
game is like at a glance looking at me
you know what I love I can equip my
favorite weapon on my back in the social
spaces so I always walk around with a
big belt fed heavy machine gun on my
back so that people know I'm not about
precision I need all the bullets even
specifically i look at the gallery and
it's got so many different facets to it
yeah it's so intricately designed yeah
like how many iterations did you go
through in designing oh god I mean we
actually um have welcomed some of the
concept artists on to the stream and
what would happen is uh you know they
would have an initial concept someone
takes that initial concept and they
literally do a paint over there like
this rocket launcher looks beautiful and
it's ornate and it's awesome and it's
definitely like an iconic weapon that
I'd love to add to my arsenal but I'm
gonna put a lot of wolves on right so
it's definitely a collaborative
experience everything starts with that
spark of creative inspiration it starts
with an idea and a sketch then it
becomes a hard surface 3d model and then
we go in we add the color and you know
the sparkle and the shine and all the
things that really make it you know the
finished product then you slide that
thing over the sandbox team they take
that and they say and a weapon this
beautiful a weapon this iconic with
these gilded figures and these wonderful
accents this needs to be amazing so
we're going to fill it up with Wolf Pack
rounds this thing's gonna be a cluster
bomb launcher you know now speaking of
weapons will there be any new weapons in
the game that haven't been in any other
games previously something brand-new
absolutely yeah we have all new armor
sets all new weapon sets they're going
to be new exotic weapons you know
they're going to be plenty of things to
add to your inventory to stone your
vault that's essentially the reward for
the action that you'll find in destiny
is you get new things you add that to
your inventory those things make you
more powerful they changed the way you
fight we're going to have new ways for
guardians to fee
powerful and to affect the way the
combat sandbox works new perks new
tactical abilities so that's the Destiny
player experience you go out you
complete your missions you defeat your
enemies you get awesome rewards that
make you feel like you're evolving and
you're becoming this legendary figure in
a game now there's also been already a
raid confirmed is there anything that
you can tell us about this raid
confirmed so we are facing off against
the Fallen befallen devil splicers are
the enemy in destiny rise of iron they
have burrowed deep into the old Golden
Age vaults that are deep beneath old
Russia and they found this terrible
technology we need to infiltrate their
enemy stronghold and hopefully destroy
the source of their power once and for
all so it delivers that raid promise
you're going to need a fire team of six
players those players are going to need
to do more than just show up they're
going to need to communicate they're
going to need to problem solve together
raids are mysteries mysteries that are
solved by new teammates and old friends
and the less we tell people about the
raid the more the payoff the greater the
payoff is now I'm you are now going to
have about three social spaces how does
Bungie balance all these different
social spaces and what kind of makes you
motivate players into going into the new
one well the FEL winter peak is the new
social space so that is the abandoned
outpost that was once inhabited by the
iron Lords there are these old legendary
figures that used to defend humanity in
ancient times they all sacrificed
themselves in the original confrontation
with this technological plague that is
the major threat that you'll find in
rise of iron different social spaces in
the game serve different purposes
especially through your progression
through the destiny story the first
place you arrived at is the tower you
know it's this bright hopeful place it's
all polished beautiful banners hanging
from the ramparts it's motivating
motivating right like you know that
you're either this may be a
post-apocalyptic game but there's still
a world worth defending humanity's still
in a pretty decent place underneath this
mysterious benefactor later on with the
house of wolves we'd opened up the reef
a lot more utilitarian very industrial
it was a spaceport occupied by you know
the awoken who was sort of like removed
themselves from human society and
that was a different mood for us to
strike employed an underground bunker it
was very different from like the
buildings which is more of like a hope
feel this was more of a there's a lot of
work to be done still yeah yeah almost
like almost like a pirate port or
something like that you know you're out
there on the outskirts you know and we
had some different experiences there you
know like that's where you participate
in the prison of elders that would be
where you go back out on the awoken
squares for revenge against the Fallen
with rise of iron we have a whole new
feel this is an abandoned place in fact
your first step like when you arrived at
the tower it was like hello welcome to
the tower this is your ghost this is
your fault when you first arrived in the
reef there was sort of this ambivalence
you know the non-player characters were
kind of glad to see you when you arrive
at fell winter peak you will be
immediately attacked okay because it has
been infiltrated by our enemy and their
first step in creating this new social
space is to capture it to reclaim it
okay these are where the monuments to
the iron Lords exist this is where Lord
Saladin the sole surviving member of the
Iron Lords has kept their memories alive
and as all of the guardians are welcome
to become iron Lords themselves step one
is to claim that outpost and set it up
as a base of operations from there we
launched off on this new story that
sends you deep into the plaguelands to
figure out what happens there sounds
like there's still a lot to be uncovered
here and I just got one more question
for you is there going to be a
collector's edition we're not making a
collector's edition certainly the Iron
galler horn which is a different variant
of the gala horns beautiful black and
silver you know walks like a gala horn
talks like a gala horn but it's just in
my opinion just a little sexier and you
can get that if you preorder rise of
iron before we launch but we are having
one version of rise of iron that people
can buy on xbox one and playstation 4
and that is available September 20s as i
write this is absolutely correct all
right thanks a lot sage so you heard it
right here you're going to see rise of
iron available on September 20th for ps4
and Xbox one and you guys don't go
anywhere we have a lot more coming up
and we're going to be talking to
psionics we have a lot of really good
interviews coming up so don't go
anywhere you stay
right here and stay tuned to gamespot
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads